Even though some of us might think
we need a traffic psychologist
when we're stuck in traffic for hours
and going crazy, it's not a real subfield.
Neither is canine psychology,
although there are psychologists
who primarily use animals
in their research.
And behavioral psychology has been used
to teach animals how to do amazing things.
For example, did you know that rats
can detect landmines through smell?
Or that dolphins can locate
underwater mines and protect boats?
Psychologists can learn a lot
from animals through research.
And psychological methods
can be used to teach animals
how to help and work with humans.